monsieur X né en 1962 et de nationalité
algérienne a 35 condamnations à son
actif après 8 mois de prison en 1984 il
enchaîne agression conduite sans permis
et violence avec armes jusqu'à sa
dernière condamnation en 2017 pour
menace de crime et délit à l'encontre
d'un magistrat monsieur X est
inexpulsable car arrivé en France avant
l'âge de 13 ans Monsieur Z né au Laos et
habitant dans les Bouches du rô a été
condamné en 2001 pour le viol de ses
filles en 2017 il est inculpé pour
conduite sans permis et l'OFPRA lui
retire le statut de réfugé pour menace à
l'ordre public Monsieur Z est
inexpulsable car résidant en France
depuis 42 ans c'est une liste de 450
profils sélectionné par les préfets à
travers l'Hexagone qui a été remonté
jusqu'à Gérald armanin et que le Figaro
a pu consulter tous dans le viseur du
ministère de l'Intérieur tous protégés
par la loi en cause les articles l6113
et l6313 du code de l'entrée et du
séjour des étrangers et du droit d'asile
arrivé avant 13 ans résident depuis 20
ans marié un citoyen français père ou
mère d'un mineur résident ou ou encore
souffrant d'une maladie grave tout un
arsenal juridique élaboré depuis les
années 80 protégerait aujourd'hui plus
de 4000 délinquants de l'expulsion
majoritairement né en Algérie au Maroc
en Tunisie mais aussi en Turquie au Mali
en Côte d'Ivoire ou encore en Georgie
dans les fêtes seul une catégorie
restreinte peut faire l'objet d'une
expulsion directe il s'agit des
individus liés à des activités à
caractère terroriste susceptible de
porter atteinte aux intérêts
fondamentaux de l'État ou encore
responsable d'appel explicit et délibéré
à la discrimination à la haine ou à la
violence mais encore faut-il être
condamné pour ces faits par exemple la
seule inscription au fichier de
traitement des signalements pour la
prévention de la radicalisation à
caractère terroriste n'est pas
suffisante pour invoquer la raison
d'État le professeur d'aras tué au
couteau par Mohamed mogoukov signalé par
la DGSI mais arrivé en France à 5 ans en
a fait les frais c'est tout l'enjeu du
texte de loi immigration en cours de
discussion au Sénat pour sortir de
l'impasse le ministre de l'Intérieur
compte notamment sur son article 9 qui
vise à aménager le régime de protection
quasi absolu dont bénéficient certains
anger lorsque ceux-ci font l'objet d'une
condamnation pour CRIM et délits graves
mais ce n'est pas tout l'expulsion n'est
possible qu'avec l'accord du pays
d'origine la France reste donc à la
mercie de l'Algérie du Mali ou encore de
la Russie souvent peu pront à
coopérer